now you mentioned Conan there and here
you are back in : days that is now the
sword & Sworcery thing is like Game of
Thrones is a show in the world and
congratulations on the finale which rock
battled it drove people crazy yes you
must have read that script with some
trepidation I did you must have been
shocked a lot of people know they were
going home
well well when they read the scripts
obviously yes yeah sometimes if you're
lucky I think you get kind of spoken to
you beforehand but no but um but the
latest the last death was definitely
there yeah that was that was a tough one
out of nowhere
now one of the people who sadly didn't
make it was of course relate husband
khal drogo yes there's a whiff of Conan
about there we go well yes there is yes
yes and all the stuff with him seemed
quite dark and brutal yes but but Bernie
there was some levity involved he wasn't
that was he's a he's a funny man a
little bit of whiskey and he's very
funny
oh it was pretty in the darkest scenes
in the darkest scenes yes so there was
there was there was the the lovely the
lovely and rape scene where I read what
could happen kind of early on in season
1 and he tried to
nervous laughter so yeah obviously
there's nudity and you kind of to try
and like lighten the mood not only was
it a sex scene but it was a kind of
violent sex scene so he decided to for
one of the scenes which was on his back
and my face he decided to not use a
modesty sock but use a beautiful pink
fluffy sock so getting that from me
looking petrified and just like did I
didn't want it to happen with just about
there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we own the Graham Norton Show and I have
some as the LaVista
[Music]
[Applause]
take